il
affrontements violents dans le nord du
tchad les troupes libyennes ne reprenne
la palmeraie daoud madonna cent mille
fans pour un concert exceptionnel dans
le parc de sceaux ce soir et puis jean
pire ce non candidat à la présidence de
la république
c'est ce qu'il a annoncé aujourd'hui à
belfort une journée supplémentaire de
détention pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
bonsoir madonna - 30
le décompte est commencé dans 30 minutes
c'est à dire quand ce journal sera
terminé madonna se présentera sur
l'immense scène du parc de sceaux devant
cent mille mado maniaque qui ont craqué
pour la réole moyennant la modique somme
de 150 francs événement musical de
l'année et succès assuré pour cette
américaine qui retrouve paris après
avoir fait chalouper les teenagers du
monde entier sur des rythmes qui font
désormais partie de la culture de notre
temps madonna à -29 en direct dans ce
journal
jean jacques dufour oui et bien depuis
le début de l'après midi des centaines
de milliers de personnes ont envahi le
parc de sceaux dessinés par le nôtre
évidemment ça ne se remarque plus
beaucoup que le parc de sceaux a été
dessiné par le nôtre c'est la première
fois sûrement qu'en france un concert
rassemble autant de monde
le public de madonna est jeune et tout à
l'heure nous avons fait un petit
micro-trottoir pour essayer de connaître
les motivations de ses fans
vous allez voir les motivations sont
extrêmement diverses
si vous venez d'où de lily ouais ouais
ouais on attend ça depuis quatre ans
coquelles à la 12 ans est habillé comme
madonna
ouais pourquoi parce que j'aime bien on
adore cette extension world en faire
j'espère qu'alain numéro 26 a vraiment
le strip tease d'enfer je n'écoute pas
tellement comme saison de la bouche bien
sûr celle de la banque seb
je suis un gars de mieux concevoir un
show à la romaine mademoiselle chicotte
interprétera 16 chansons échangera 16
fois de costumes 1
par chance on est alors plus que vous
vous n'avez pas la chance d'être ici au
parc de sceaux on a pris un extrait d'un
de ses clips et on va vous le donner en
avant-première 28 minutes avant le
concert de madonna
m
non
pas
voilà beaucoup de monde pour ce concert
beaucoup de vedettes aussi alain delon
lui s'est rendu aujourd'hui en
hélicoptère grâce à antenne 2 alain
delon s'est rendu en hélicoptère à sow
vous allez le voir sur ces images
je vous rappelle qu alain delon vous
sera le 7 septembre toute la journée sur
antenne 2 le voici
il va se poser dans quelques instants
derrière la scène où se produit madonna
voilà c'est juste le départ je sais pas
si on va voir l'arrivée
et l'organisation ala la foule
jamais vu ça
regarde caricom
cours
wild eyes
voilà des images impressionnantes
charles aznavour est avec nous sur ce
plat tout nous parlons d'autre chose
tout à l'heure avec lui mais avant cela
une règle une réaction de charles au
phénomène madonna alors d'abord est ce
que vous aimez vous allez y aller je
crois que tout de suite après le journal
non ma fille il ya les majors moi j'ai
travaillé beaucoup aujourd'hui j'ai
répété je suis fatigué je n'irai pas non
mais sinon non puisque je n'étais pas
fatiguée je n'avais pas voyager demain j
aurais été pourquoi pas moi je trouve
que c'est un phénomène très agréable sur
tout ce qui se passe d'extraordinaire
dans notre métier doit nous devons nous
réjouir mais qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire cet engouement de la jeunesse
pour séverine stars comme madonna
je ne suis pas d'accord je suis un petit
peu dépassé parce que l'époque n'est pas
la même
l'engouement n'était pas le même à
l'époque où j'ai connu
bon les grand engouement pour traîner
pour tino pour pour piaf ce gigantisme
et d'extraire c'est fantastique quand
même ça ressemble pas trop à votre
public
or je crois pas qu une grande différence
pour qu'on y va pour des motivations
différentes et pour autre chose que vous
savez les chansons chante au coeur aux
jambes au ventre les jeunes se sont
exprimés d'ailleurs chacun avait une
motivation différente tant que s'il
formule à bouger très très bien merci
charles a tout de suite on vous retrouve
la dengue dans quelques instants
voilà à ozu change de mètres c'est le
drapeau libyen qui flotte désormais sur
la palmeraie conquise il ya plusieurs
semaines par les troupes d'hissène habré
information démentie hier par n'djamena
mais confirmée aujourd'hui par six
journalistes occidentaux qui ont pu se
rendre sur place
correspondances téléphoniques de
l'envoyé spécial de la lfp en libye
chronique d'une candidature annoncée une
présidentielle plus un jean pierre
chevènement candidat à la candidature de
la présidence de la république et bien
c'est fait il y a eu la joie ni le pen
rocard et puis arlette laguiller avec
cette décision prise aujourd'hui par
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale
le clan des prétendants s'élargit ils
sont cinq désormais et chacun sait qu on
en restera probablement pas là sur les
raisons de cette candidature attendue
le reportage de pascal gimme énigmatique
le lion de grès rose veille toujours sur
la ville mais derrière cette trop
fameuse ligne bleue des vosges
c'est l'horizon des présidentielles qui
pointent belfort ce matin jean pierre
chevènement joue les sphinx tranquille
michel rocard n'est pas un problème mais
il m'avait pas du tout et de quoi mais
eux-mêmes pourrait-il me vouloir
pourriez lui faire de l'ombre
et pourquoi puisqu'il candidat oui
aujourd'hui c'est le soleil ce n'est
plus un secret le maire de belfort entre
à son tour dans la danse sur l'air des
copains d'abord deux pôles emploi
croissance europe défense chevènement
dessine aujourd'hui l'autoportrait du
bon candidat
rappelons qu'il fut lui un des pères
fondateurs du ps avant d'être un
ministre populaire jean pierre
chevènement s'efforce donc de voile et
la candidature de michel rocard au nom
de la ligne du parti
lionel josse pas notre premier
secrétaire définissez ainsi les qualités
qu'ils font à notre candidat il doit
rassembler les socialistes il doit
représenter dans le pays quelque chose
de plus que le parti socialiste est en
même temps il doit respecter pleinement
le parti dont il est issu et bien je me
reconnais pleinement dans cette
définition
bien sûr si françois mitterrand se
représente jean pierre chevènement
s'effacera il l'a déjà fait en 81 cette
candidature à la candidature en fait une
double détente
d'abord jean pierre chevènement entend
rappeler à ses amis socialistes qu'il
existe et qu'il a un projet bien à lui
c'est donc un objectif stratégique
incarner une alternative un discours qui
jugent trop gestionnaire seront
recentrées et puis il ya une
préoccupation tactique évidente
contrecarrer les projets de michel
rocard le seul candidat socialiste
déclaré à ce jour visite de jacques
chirac au français du bout du monde
avant de rejoindre demain françois
mitterrand à québec pour l'ouverture du
sommet sur la francophonie
le premier ministre s'est arrêté
aujourd'hui à saint pierre et miquelon
avant-postes de la france perdue entre
terre-neuve et l'extrême nord du canada
l'archipel éprouve depuis quelques
années de plus en plus de difficultés à
vivre des zones de pêche contesté par
son puissant voisin
à saint pierre et miquelon jacques
chirac a évoqué ce conflit reportage
jean-louis la scène on vit comme une
aimant dans cet archipel du bout du
monde qui lie à issy trois pôles
d'intérêt la pêche encore la pêche est
toujours la pêche et il est de fait que
cette quasi mono activité occupe la
plupart des 6000 habitants de saint
pierre et miquelon une mono activité qui
pose problème depuis que le canada tout
proches contestent des zones de pêche et
impose en quelque sorte des quotas aux
chalutiers français
s'agissant des problèmes de négociation
je l'évoquais tout à l'heure de
négociation et l'arbitrage enfin de
contentieux je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
je me rends donc au canada je vous
répète que la position que je soutiens
vers dans un esprit d'amitié avec le
mythe
premier ministre canadien celle
d'ailleurs que le gouvernement soutient
depuis alan ennemi c'est une position
non agressive mais de fermeté exclusive
de tout compromis et que l'on peut tout
naturellement exposés sans ambages à
quelqu'un que l'on considère comme un
hells en dehors des problèmes
industriels le premier ministre a parlé
désenclavement aérien et francophonie
accueil sympathique de la population
discussions bon enfant avec les élus
locaux
jacques chirac aura en une demi-journée
fait le tour des problèmes de l'archipel
dans son entourage on insiste sur le
fait qu'il est le premier homme d'état à
avoir rendu visite et à saint pierre et
à miquelon un geste qui n'est pas ici
passer inaperçu partie de cache-cache en
nouvelle calédonie d'un côté la police
chargée d'empêcher les manifestations de
rue de l'autre les indépendantistes du
fln crise qui tentent de contourner la
loi
voici pour l'ambiance à quinze jours du
référendum prévu pour le 13 septembre
prochain
la campagne officielle pour cette
consultation s'ouvre demain
reportage rachid arhab philipp etter
un crs qui explique dans un anglais
presque parfait à des touristes néo
zélandais que l'accès à la plage est
interdite pour cause de risques de
manifestation ce matin en effet le bruit
a couru dans nouméa que les
indépendantistes avait l'intention
d'organiser une opération appelée marc
et loire une opération qui aurait
consisté à envahir une plage
habituellement fréquentés par des
touristes
finalement les crs sont restés sur le
pavé tout près de la plage mais les
manifestants eux ne sont pas venus le
fln k s a visiblement choisi de jouer au
chat et à la souris avec les équipes de
télévision mais aussi et surtout avec
les forces de l'ordre qui entendent bien
faire respecter l'interdiction de tout
rassemblement jusqu'au côté rpcr jacques
lafleur le leader des anti
indépendantistes estime que tout ce qui
s'est passé depuis une semaine en
nouvelle calédonie est un coup monté
les événements se sont produits il ya
quelques jours j'ai l'explication ne les
lâche chine les événements que régulière
grave qui a eu des répercussions à paris
et qu'il
on était hanté l'objet d'une
consultation qui à mon avis est frigide
meeting classique du côté du rpcr
manifestations en tout genre pour le fn
15 la campagne électorale est cette fois
ci bien lancée en nouvelle calédonie à
nouméa où les rumeurs d faire le plus
vite que les vagues du pacifique ont dit
ce soir que les indépendantistes
voudraient occuper les églises
à l'heure de la messe du dimanche matin
on dit aussi que dans les prochains
jours le flq aurait l'intention de
bloquer les grands magasins de nouméa
en l'envoyant ses militants les uns
après les autres acheter un chewing gum
des actions qui peuvent faire sourire
mais qui ont le don d'énerver les anti
indépendantistes des actions qui sont
également difficiles à contrôler par la
police
cory aquino troque le gant de velours
pour une main de fer elle a promis
aujourd'hui pour la première fois de
chati les responsables du coup d'état
qui a fait 55 morts hier
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le calme est
revenu un peu partout sur le territoire
mais chacun à manille s'interroge sur
l'avenir d'un régime ébranlé à quatre
reprises par la dissidence des
militaires
gilles rabin il était déjà l'homme fort
du régime de cory aquino ce soir son
autorité son rang qu'en grandi de
l'échec de cette cinquième tentative de
coup d'état aux philippines
cette fois ci le général ramos n'a pas
fait de quartier contre cette
insurrection qui le contesté lui au
moins autant que la présidente
il a fait donner les chars les canons et
même les bombardiers et ruines de ce qui
a été pendant deux jours le camp
retranché des insurgés témoigne ce soir
de cette volonté gouvernementale d'en
finir vite
pour la première fois en 18 mois et cinq
tentatives de putsch des factions
militaires rivales se sont entretués
dans manille et le sens abondamment
coulé corps et à quinio convoi assisté
sur ces images aux obsèques d'un garde
du corps qui s'est sacrifié pour sauver
son fils
correa quinio c'est que son pouvoir sans
ébranler de cette nouvelle crise
quant au chef des insurgés il a réussi à
prendre la fuite le colonel gregorio
gringo onas en fait tu es devenu célèbre
autant pour s'être rangé très tôt aux
côtés de la présidente que pour ses
allures de rambo philippins
aujourd'hui sa tête est mise à prix et
l'ordre a été donné à tous de l'abattre
sans sommation afrique du sud la grève
des mineurs tourne au drame deux mineurs
noah ont été abattus hier dans une mine
d'or ce qui porte à 10 le nombre des
victimes depuis le début de ce conflit
un conflit pour l'instant dans l'impasse
puisque lé angloamerican la plus grande
compagnie minière sud africaine a
annoncé hier le licenciement de 12 mille
salariés en grève depuis maintenant deux
semaines geneviève moll rien de réglé
cette nuit après sept heures de
négociations entre le syndicat national
des mineurs sud africain est la
principale compagnie minière du pays
l'anglo américaine offre un seul mais
les pourparlers devraient reprendre
demain aujourd'hui au 20e jour d'une
grève déclenchée pour des augmentations
de salaire par plus de 250 mille mineurs
le bilan est lourd
onze morts dont deux grévistes tués hier
dans des affrontements avec les forces
de l'ordre
il ya un non grévistes poignardé et
brûlé par ailleurs 34 mille mineurs ont
déjà été licenciés par l'anglo american
tout cela se déroule dans un climat
encore aggravée par le nouveau tour de
vis que le gouvernement botha vient de
donner à la presse sud africaine
désormais en effet le ministre des
affaires intérieures pour a censuré un
article ou une publication
s'il représente je cite une menace pour
la sécurité du public ou le maintien de
l'ordre et retarde l'accomplissement de
l'état d'urgence trente-deux personnes
j'ai bien dit 32 se sont suicidés
collectivement corée du sud un geste
décidé par une femme se faisant passer
pour une ds aux yeux des membres d'une
secte
parmi les victimes de nombreux enfants
incendie dans une centrale nucléaire de
taïwan le feu aurait pris dans un
bâtiment situé à 400 mètres de deux
réacteurs atomiques
l'incendié aurait été maîtrisé les deux
réacteurs sont intactes d'après l'un des
responsables de la centrale
reprise des raids irakien dans le golfe
selon des sources maritimes un pétrolier
iranien auraient été touchées par
l'aviation de bagdad
aujourd'hui et pour finir cette
information que vous trouverez dans
l'hebdomadaire le point de lundi wahid
gordji ce ressortissant iranien dans son
ambassade
emprisonné alors à sa fin on part
emprisonné dans l'ambassade à son
ambassade à paris aurait dû être expulsé
en 1985
c'est l'ancien préfet de police guy
forget qui en avait fait la demande
joxe à l'époque ça bouge sur l'île
d'elbe libération ce matin d'un otage
par les mutins de la prison italienne de
porto 1 0
on dit aussi que mario tutti militants
d'extrême droite ne serait plus le chef
des preneurs d'otage ce sont deux
détenus de droit commun qui l'aurait
remplacé dans ce rôle
quoi qu'il en soit l'heure semble être
maintenant à la négociation
le point sur la situation autour du
pénitencier avec patrice voleurs les
négociations sortent de la prison
rebelles et forces de l'ordre disputent
maintenant par télévision interposée
ce matin une équipe de la rai la
télévision italienne est convoqué par
les mutins elle ressort de la prison
avec une bande magnétique a diffusé au
journal télévisé message des rebelles
il n'y a aucune divergence entre nous
chacun joue son rôle
une intervention pour couper court à une
rumeur qui pourrait ce matin mario tout
petits à l'origine de la prise d'otage
ne serait plus maître de la situation
réponse indirecte des autorités
italiennes dans le même journal télévisé
aucun hélicoptère ne pourra décoller de
la cour de la prison
avec 15 personnes à bord et le plein de
carburant un bras de fer psychologique
au cinquième jour de la rébellion cet
après midi et pour la première fois
depuis le début de la mutinerie
les familles des otages ont rencontré le
ministre de la justice
il leur a confirmé la volonté de son
gouvernement négocié dans la fermeté
vous connaissez la mama la bohème toutes
ses chansons vous les avez à un moment
ou un autre fredonner et puis plus rien
charles aznavour l'auteur de ces succès
resté silencieux pendant plusieurs
années
charles aznavour rompt le silence il
sera du 29 septembre au 8 novembre au
palais des sports et sort un nouvel
album le mois prochain lors charles
aznavour est avec nous sur ce plateau
merci charles d'être venu alors première
question pour une si pourquoi une si
longue absence au mieux réponse ne sera
pas au palais des sports mais au palais
des congrès paris on va par là une si
longue absence parce que finalement bon
jeu venait très souvent en france
puisque
vacant unis voir des amis juin une
émission de télévision et puis on a
l'impression qu'on peut toujours dire
chez soi facilement et qu'on n'a pas le
temps d'aller ailleurs
et combien bruit demande d'ailleurs j'ai
fait souvent le tour du monde
et qu'avez vous fait pendant ces années
à l'extérieur vous n'avez plus chanter
ou presque je chantais vous en déplaise
sont bien dansez maintenant c'est j'ai
fait cela je chante et non pas en france
enfin que j'ai fait de la télévision en
france pour non pas que le public se
disent que j'existais plus mais je
chante et surtout à l'étranger j'ai
toujours pensé que j'étais un bon
produit d'exportation alors il faudrait
il ne faut rien cacher vous êtes partis
sur une brouille vous avez dit les
choses à l'époque sur une grande partie
sur wii un fort coup tête sur une
brouille avec avec une certaines
administrations mais pas avec la france
la france n'est pas une administration
la france et la france alors que nouveau
l'honneur de votre retour en france
maintenant c'était déjà planifié depuis
pas mal de temps
et puis à chaque fois il y avait il ya
un grain de sable dans le dans le
mécanisme allant des bons ballons on le
fera dans les prochaines plus l'année
prochaine et puis la salle est pas libre
au moment où il le faut que finalement
on a eu toutes les libertés toutes les
possibilités
le palais des congrès était livre à ce
moment là alors là j'ai pu décider deux
ans à l'avancé quand même alors c'est
qui maintenant le aznavour nouveau si on
peut appeler ça comme ça il n'ya pas las
d'un jour nouveau
on ne peut pas y avoir deux navires
nouveau je pense qu'on ne peut pas voir
plusieurs révolutions dans une vie mont
sutton aznavour qui a mûri qu'un langage
un petit peu plus un peu plus agressif
peut-être mais je chante toujours des
chansons d'amour mais plus approprié à
mon âge
alors vous avez vu madonna hier elle à
elle offert donc cinq cent mille francs
pour la défense contre le sida
alors il ya des chanteurs à message est
ce que est ce que vous avez des causes
est ce que vous vous sentez concerné par
un certain nombre de causes est ce que
vous êtes prêt vous à faire un certain
nombre de gestes comme cela mais j'en
fais bon j'en fais dans différents pays
seront pas on parle de madonna qui vient
de me faire ici et on ne parle matière
non pas de ceux qui le font dans le pays
différents mais je participe un nombre
de choses pour l'enfance et puis à la
rentrée
lorsque je serai sur place lorsque vous
pourrez défendre une cause je voudrais
bien qu'on parle d'un petit peu et
beaucoup même de la sclérose en plaques
et je prendrai fait et cause pour cette
pose là vous resterez longtemps en
france
oh oui je vais rester pas mal de temps
en france combien pourrait en suisse à
bachir est fermée fin de semaine en
suisse pour aller pour aller embrasser
mes enfants qui seront les écoles bien
sûr mais j'avais il faut pas dire la
suisse la suisse est à deux pas de la
france la suisse et la langue française
la suisse et c'est comme si on était ici
merci charles et donc mon retour mais si
les dieux du stade dans la ville
éternelle à rome se sont ouverts
aujourd'hui les championnats du monde
d'athlétisme demain le choc de titans
que tout le monde attend carl lewis ben
johnson sur 100 m mais dès aujourd'hui
plusieurs épreuves au programme le
marathon féminin et le lancement du
poids francis maroteaux
athlétisme le deuxième championnat du
monde la grand messe à rome dans
l'enceinte du stade olympique avec la
cérémonie d'ouverture pour 1500 athlètes
représentant 165 pays spectacle à gros
budget 700 millions de francs parce que
l'athlétisme aujourd'hui c'est aussi un
superbe show première épreuve le
marathon féminin 42km 0,95 à parcourir à
courir pour quarante deux concurrentes
hasard ou symboles et au départ 27
degrés à l'ombre pour les concurrentes
parmi elles deux françaises
jocelyne villeton et marianne lui perdu
dans la masse au départ mais pas à
l'arrivée jocelyne villeton troisième
gagnante la portugaise rosa mota dès la
sortie du stade elle décide de courir à
son rythme
troisième aux jeux olympiques de los
angeles en 1984 première à rome entre
temps de l'or en suisse au lancer du
poids avec le géant suisse glencore deux
mètres qui réussi un jet à 22 m 23
gunther remporte le concours devant le
recordman du monde l'italien andrei dans
un stade qui a tant qui attend l'arrivée
nocturne de rosa mota la portugaise
remporte donc ce marathon
un marathon qui est bien terminée malgré
ses doutes malgré ces craintes en deux
heures 25 minutes et 16 secondes nouveau
record des championnats du monde dans
notre journal de 13 heures nous étions
en direct à 300 mètres sous terre avec
des spéléologues du vercors reportage
réalisé à l'occasion du grand prix du
film spéléo et bien ce prix a été
attribué cet après midi par un jury
international à gibson pour les cuves
des nuits résultats du tiercé
aujourd'hui à vincennes pour gagner il
fallait jouer le vin le 3 et le 7
rapports dans l'ordre 11900 de francs 50
pour cinq points dans un ordre différent
2380 francs 50 toujours pour 5 points et
puis pronostic de pire et de braise pour
le tiercé quarté + de demain prix lancel
voici les numéros qu'il faudra à jouer
le 7 le 15 le 5 le 14 le 6 le 3 le 10 et
le 17 le rock and roll des retours
difficiles ou grand calme sur le front
des routes
oui paradoxalement effectivement ce fut
le presque le grand calme
aujourd'hui nous avons pratiquement
connu que des encombrements nizon de
deux fans week-end tout à fait classique
dans la vallée du rhône
certains d'entre vous ont précipité leur
leur retour puisque vous êtes
certainement rentrer en début de semaine
il faisait pas beau d'autres
certainement prolongent leurs vacances
en dix se disent enfin finalement il
croit beau encore demain et vous avez
raison et résultats bien aujourd'hui
c'était très calme sur les routes
actuellement une difficulté peut même
avant de parler météo une difficulté au
parc de sceaux deviner ce qui se passe
c'est madonna qui bouchonnent à ces deux
concerts de madonna
alors revenons en à notre météo vous
avez la photo satellite qui est déjà là
elle vous explique tout et vous explique
le soleil parce que nous avons un énorme
anticyclone mais vraiment énorme
l'anticyclone des açores qui est présent
sur pratiquement toute la france et même
et même sur l'atlantique alors ce qui
nous inquiète ce sont ces petits nuages
ce chapelet de nuages qui se trouve sur
l'espagne ils vont grimper tout
doucement doucement dans la journée de
demain et surtout dans celle de lundi et
ils vont nous amener les orages nous
n'en sommes pas là demain c'est le grand
beau et c'est le grand show avec tout de
suite le show de la météo
voici un grand ciel bleu quelques
corolle nuageuse encore en début de
matinée
c'est la carte de samedi j'ai vu samedi
non c'est dimanche et enfin c'est pas
grave c'est la même carte dans quelques
corolle nuageux sur le nord
demain matin en début de matinée et
ensuite il fera très très beau sur
l'ensemble
français température nous allons les
voir elles sont à la hausse bien entendu
puisqu'il va faire beaucoup beaucoup de
choses et beaucoup de soleil pardon avec
des températures qui vont aller de 22° à
cherbourg jusqu'à 27 degrés à rennes
tours et paris voilà pour la moitié nord
et sur la moitié sud nous repartons de
27 degrés du côté de bourges
clermont-ferrand et lyon jusqu'à 32
degrés à perpignan agen et biarritz et
demain et bien nous serons donc le
dimanche 30 août je dis bien le dimanche
30 août le soleil va se lever à 7h05 se
coucher à 20h37 et nous ferons les
fiacres jeu possible vous en connaissez
enfin fou de cocher quand même merci
laurent et puis une dernière minute
cette information monsieur mitterrand
qui a reçu monsieur balladur qui assure
l'intérim du premier ministre
aujourd'hui je cite pour s'entretenir
avec lui des derniers développements de
la situation au tchad
c'est un communiqué de la présidence de
la république qui nous apprend cette
information voilà fin de cette édition
merci de l'avoir suivi mais restez avec
nous sur antenne 2 vous retrouverez
aznavour dans une émission qui va suivre
paris au mois d'août prochaine édition
23h30
jacques merlino je vous retrouverai
demain à 13h bonne soirée